[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
as you probably really heard Android 7.0
nougat is officially out it's public and
it's available and I've been using the
public beta on my Nexus 6p for a little
while like the past couple of weeks and
I've liked it a lot now I've already
done a video of all the new features of
Android n so that videos linked here
that's our full rundown that's
everything
this video is more of my thoughts on the
final version that will be available
when everyone starts to get it so when
using 7.0 for the past couple weeks the
biggest change for daily use for me has
been the notifications for sure the
grouping the more info the quick replies
the quick settings all that stuff
particularly the way notifications are
organized does have the biggest impact
they're all grouped together now which
means if you get multiple notifications
from the same app they all bundle
together and then you can separate them
out when you want to take action on them
so like Gmail uses this really well it's
in messaging apps we all do the same
thing no matter how many emails you get
you can interact with them one by one in
your notifications you can reply to one
at a time you can delete one at a time
read them one by one it's like a whole
new app up there and then the quick
settings up top are easy to get used to
also they're really convenient and quick
to get to and you can choose exactly
which controls show up here in the quick
settings too so if you use the
flashlight a lot you can put it up there
on the top or if you switch to night
mode a lot you can move that up too
all of this is customizable which is
really nice now the second big change
that I noticed in everyday use is
definitely the double tapping
multitasking window - quick switch I
used it a lot it's one of those things
where you start to love it and then you
really miss it on other phones it just
saves a lot of time and is convenient
and it just works so that's good - split
screen multitasking is another big
addition you hold the multitasking
button take another app and you get in
but I didn't really use this that much
so it's been built into so many other
phones that I guess it made sense to
build it into stock Android - so now
bigger phones can feel like mini tablets
and you can have multiple apps open at
the same time in portrait or landscape
but I didn't release as much in the LG
or Samsung phones that did this
beforehand so now I also didn't use it
much with the Nexus but if you are a
person that use it a lot in those other
phones thing will be happy to see it
here and then one
biggest behind-the-scenes changes in
android 7.0 is in the battery life
Department with those on the go so you
know how tablets have some parts of the
day where they're being used a lot
heavily for like all types of media but
then other parts of the day when they're
really not being used that much and
they're just on a shelf somewhere one
they're not being used much they go into
this low-power state and that's called
doze now Android 7.0 brings what they're
calling doze on the go which should let
your phone go into this low-power state
when it's not being used so times like
when it's sitting on a couch or in your
pocket or something and it knows it's
not being woken up then in theory it'll
save battery the same way a tablet does
I personally haven't noticed a huge
boost in battery on my Nexus 6p from
when I was using marshmallow but again
that was just the public beta so we'll
keep testing that and hopefully it does
get better there's a bunch of other
smaller things that really bring
together Android 7.0 as a complete
update there's a bunch of new updated
emojis that all look slightly more
human-like
there is Virtual Reality support
built-in for when we start seeing more
daydream compatible hardware and the JIT
compiler and the Vulcan API for gaming
performance for the apps that will
support it the update process is better
boot times are faster you can now log in
with facial recognition by adding a
trusted face which is interesting and
you can also now mess around with the
DPI settings with a setting called
display size to make this appear larger
or appear smaller throughout the whole
UI there's even now keyboard themes
where you can use an existing one that's
built in with new color schemes from
light to dark colors or you can even
make your own out of an image you having
a gallery and maybe weirdest of all the
easter egg is a little more weird it
lets you bring a cat bowl to the quick
settings and leave out a snack of your
choice to catch a little cat it's kind
of weird yeah but when at the end of
this site down at the bottom of the
official release they also mentioned
that the first phone that we'll be
shipping with Android 7.0 out the box
will be the LGV 20 not a nexus alright
so I'm looking forward to seeing that
phone apparently that's coming very soon
if they're going to be launching with
that fresh OS right out the box so if
you're a nexus user you can grab this
update right now you can join the public
beta and download android 7.0 today I'll
have a link below the like button if you
want to do that otherwise if you're not
that's probably a low chance of you
seeing this
software and like the next couple months
but hopefully as many phones as possible
get updated to get these new features
anyway that's pretty much it thanks for
watching this quick video and I'll talk
to you guys again very soon in the next
one peace
[Music]